so many diners today are looking for
healthier options while still enjoying
fresh and imaginative dishes and harvest
at bellagio provides just that joining
me now to tell us more about their menu
and why it's such a welcome change of
pace in las vegas is executive chef
isaiah torres welcome chef thank you so
much for having me we were just talking
off the air about some of the incredible
dishes and we're going to show some of
them to you that you have at harvest but
you really wanted to create a place
where someone who eats
vegan can go and not worry about what's
going on in the kitchen absolutely so
it's very difficult for most of our
diners to come in and
have a complete experience and a
cohesive experience because most of the
time they have to ask the server
find out research and instead we're
trying to make it so that it when our
vegan diners come in they they see
the the menu they can choose off of it
and it's done and we're going to make
something that sounds incredible
absolutely
my favorite fruit
watermelon and this watermelon you're
seasoning it but before you season the
watermelon this is where it starts in
this in this brine right yes so that
brine is a very simple brine we just
have sugar
salt and some peppercorns in there how
long do you leave that in there just a
few hours okay
it depends on the thickness that you cut
it
obviously we're going to make ours a lot
thicker than uh you would at home maybe
but
we want that so that when our diners
come in they have a nice meaty portion
so this is a watermelon steak and it
looks it looks like a fillet absolutely
you seasoned it with what so this is a
chipotle
guajillo powder with salt
onion powder garlic powder so a lot of
different flavors that we're trying to
uh bring into that watermelon steak as
well and then we're gonna put it right
in the pan here nice and hot i'm gonna
sear that off
it's just so interesting that we're
using a fruit as a meat right yeah and
it's you know it's just so that we can
bring that savory flavor out uh bring
something that's exciting and different
and and uh
something that is filling
a lot of the times that our vegan diners
will go out they eat
salads or they'll eat sides and then
they won't be able to have something
that actually is filling as a whole
entree or appetizer or side and then it
becomes difficult for them to eat
getting the smells off of this is so
great we have a minute left so okay so
let's get let's get a little bit quicker
yes absolutely we actually have one in
the oven right now so we can get this
going our chef he had it ready to go yes
so
absolutely this is going to go right
underneath i'm going to just season that
up with a little lemon vinaigrette
all right and then i'm going to place
this down on to the plate
because this lemon
brings a lot of acidity back to the
steak itself
and then
get rid of that
this is a stone fruit chutney that we
put on the side
all right so nice and savory again this
is made with salt sugar
vinegar and all of the beautiful stone
fruits that we have in the summer all
part of the new vegan absolutely harvest
epilagi so as we see this searing up
here it's going to get a little hotter
maybe once it gets nice and hot you get
this beautiful color over here
and then we slice it up
so
as
we plate this
we'll layer it for our guests right and
you see it actually takes on that
texture it looks fantastic right and we
finish this off
absolutely so we finished this off with
a little masago ahrari which is rice
crackers uh-huh
the taste the textures the spices
everything that you use we want to treat
it like it's a true steak and then just
a little bit of salt to finish that off
all right let's give it a taste and
people want to
check out the new vegan menu and the
entire menu over at harvest how do they
do can they make reservations make
reservations at bellagio.com or uh you
know come and see us amazing whoa
i'm gonna eat off that beer menu we'll
be right back this is